[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kevin millar can help us out major
league baseball network analyst and uh
he of course won a world series
championship with the red sox mala will
be out there with uh mlb intentional
talk that will be from the field of
dreams in iowa today that starts at five
eastern millard joins us now from from
the corn field
hey
i'm looking for my six my six four three
or five three you know i can ground
short with the best of them but a lot of
guys looking for their hormone balls i'm
gonna tell you right now
there it is danny there it is
the corn
i just want to tell you one thing i'm
gonna give you something right now okay
all right corn sweats it creates
humidity on the field today is gonna be
a hundred degrees what's the word
benny
evapo transportation that's what's
sweating up the corn so just so you know
there you go and you're welcome
if you hit it into the corn it's a home
run
yes it's a home run if you hit it into
the corn you circle the pillows how
what's the uh distance there down the
line in center field
you know what's a great point playing i
think this is about 302 to right always
they always give like right field the
cheap side how about how about the pool
hitters like myself and you because
you're a full hitter back in eighth
grade i think you led the league in home
runs
left field's about 323.
okay and and what about dead center
400. now that's that's that's the
regular field i'm giving you okay here
dead center is probably about
three 340.
and you do have those light poles that
are in the field of play
yes light poles are in the field of
plates almost like the gold pulse in the
end zone in football heads up coming in
high
all right um what kind of alterations
did they make for this field so it is
like this is a
this is a major league game tonight this
isn't an exhibition
no this is a big event a couple years
they've had this and the plans major
league baseball's done a great job this
is the movie set field right here so out
here is the movie set field as you can
see
over there is to feel the dreams field
that they have just absolutely nailed it
i mean that the fence looks like a a
rustic but it it looks like a wall but
it's padded uh there's 8 000 seats you
have to have a seat you know to be in
there there's nowhere really to stand so
it's a cozy feel and it's exactly what
you think father-son playing a game of
catch
kevin costner going to be there
kevin costner's going to be on the show
today he's here me and big papi were
having a cocktail last night and there
goes costner walking right by i mean
we're in iowa we're yeah everybody's
right there in the same spot and i'm
telling you i got a chance to hang out
with his his crew
they love him they say he's a wonderful
man all right so the field of dreams
field is not used for tonight's game
it's the other one that major league
baseball went in and did they they just
created a temporary field did they wipe
out all the corn there to create this uh
new baseball field
yeah for those that never been here
which is a lot of us
that there's nothing but beautiful farms
and corn and the vision to have to
create it's almost like you know steve
wynn and shadow creek in vegas you know
going back 25 years ago it's just a
desert flat and then you create this
golf course that's like heaven it's the
same feel it's absolutely just gorgeous
they created this field it's impeccable
it's like the masters it's there's not a
there's not a there's not a row out of
place and this is like i said the movie
set field yeah and you get over there
it's just it's it's breathtaking it
really is it's breathtaking
what are some of the other cool things
that you have out there that people will
be able to tune in and watch
well you're going to have some really
cool good-looking players as you know
your shirt off judge and stan obviously
you got the white sox you got the
yankees this is a real game
this is an event it's exciting and uh
you know it kind of it kind of
kick-starts the boys summer going into
september for these playoff pushes uh
your favorite movie baseball movie of
all time is
bold durham hands down it's as realistic
as you can have aside from you know her
being in the clubhouse but it's exactly
it you got the high good tall hard
thrown pitcher that can't throw strikes
and then here you go you got crash davis
uh you know doing his thing behind the
plate what's the craziest story that you
experienced in the minor leagues
oh danny uh
craziest experience john roskos
he's a sheriff now in uh new mexico
albuquerque and the reason why i'm
bringing his name up because we were
just there on a tournament but he would
ground out to shortstop that's just this
is and he would stick his head into the
toilet now you know finally toilets
there's everything in there danny
everything seeds dip chew whatever you
want to do
and he would flush it so when he would
struggle head would go in the toilet
come out and give him this one he was a
second
second-round
draft kick but great guy now a sheriff
it's a it's a rally swirly
it's a rally swirly i like that you know
and then karaoke right down the road in
clinton clinton iowa and uh yeah it's
the minor leagues right uh which team
playing tonight will go further in the
playoffs the white sox are the yankees
i think the white sox yankees are making
a run yankees i mean we all thought
yankees were done and then they go out
and get andrew heaney and haney and
obviously make the moves with rizzo
and gallo but you know then the covet
thing hits and the rizzo back out so
they dealt with a lot but they put
themselves right back in position red
sox have struggled bunnied a little bit
they they blew out tampa last night but
i think the white sox are a really good
ball club well behave out there uh are
you taking bp today
i did yesterday john smoltz gave up a
home run to a 14 year old dead center
here in the corn
i did a lot of ground balls at shortstop
danny as you know wait sure you had
smoltz on the mound throwing bp
oh yeah so with poppy and i were gonna
have a home run derby and then you know
it was funny because uh i'm getting a
bunch of texts like that's not fair he
he's way better than you i go i get it
guys he got here just a tick late
we had uh smoltz throw a little bp to me
like i said a lot of ground balls and
then there was the little league guys
that were coming to play and a 14 year
old took smoke's dead center so it was
interesting uh he wasn't happy you know
supposedly he's a competitive son of a
guy he was kind of happy i'm like bro
we're at the field of dreams it's okay
johnny no you got to throw you got to
knock the kid down with the next pitch
[Music]
you know what i think of you to get
another bat i think the kid was going
down
great to talk to you buddy thank you
kevin
you got it brother we'll see ya that's
kevin millar he and uh adnan virk will
co-host mlb network's intentional talk
that'll be live from the field of dream
site in iowa today at 5 eastern that
game is a little after 7 eastern